c'est trop loin de loups trouverez que
europe consacrée à l'abstention de
l'abstention et les élections
européennes vont de pair et ça depuis
1979 date du premier vote pour les
députés européens en france 39,3 %
d'abstention cette année là mais les
français n'étaient pas les seuls mauvais
élèves
pour prendre l'exemple de rome en avait
plutôt l'impression ce mâtin que les
électeurs courait vers la mer et des
plages plutôt que vers les bureaux de
vote jusqu'à britanniques sur trois
seulement et s'est rendu aux urnes
on pourrait presque appeler cela
l'indifférence totale
cinq ans plus tard nouveau vote pour le
parlement européen et l'indifférence est
encore plus grande
43 3% d'abstention en france et même
ceux qui se déplacent dans le bureau de
vote ne sont pas convaincus européenne
plus ou moins les années passent et les
électeurs désertent de plus en plus les
élections européennes
la barre des 50 % d'abstentionnistes et
même franchi alors médias politiques
sociologues commencent à s'interroger
sur les raisons de ce désintérêt
les politiques doivent ils revoir leur
programme les médias doivent t'ils mieux
expliquer les institutions et les enjeux
européens
question à méditer pour les prochaines
élections mais rien n'est fait
la tension continue de progresser
pourtant paradoxalement le parlement
européen a de plus en plus de pouvoir
mais toujours ceux des intérêts en
france avec 57 2 % d'abstention pour les
élections de 2004 un record qui
continuera à être battu pour atteindre
57 2 6 % d'abstention aux dernières
élections
pourtant le parlement européen avait
fait les campagnes de pub pour inciter à
voter directement
campagne qui visait les jeunes très
représentés dans les abstentionnistes
mais rien n'est fait en 2014
75% des français de 18 à 24 ans n'ont
pas voté kishi pense au japon a été mise
au courant tout simplement jeu
totalement oublié et du coup j'ai pas
été fair ma carte d'électeur et ceux d
intérêt croissant pour les élections
européennes n'est pas propre qu'à la
france tous les électeurs européens sont
dans le même cas
la courbe de l'abstention aux élections
européennes ne cesse d'augmenter depuis
[Musique]